c'est toujours un peu moi c'est toujours
un peu maladroit moi je vais aller dans
le sens de gilles parce que c'est
toujours maladroit ce qu'ils font quand
ils font ça il faut il n'arrive pas à
ceux ramenés à ramener les choses qu'il
est qu'il est qui les fait vivre c'est
des gens qui les font vivre sans les
gens sans les gens ils sont personne
c'est pas des métiers ordinaire c'est
moi je dis ici que c'est pas un métier
c'est une récré c'est une récré pas mais
il va sur scène il a été sur scène
longtemps mais c'est du travail mais
c'est
aussi moins vertige et le droit d'ériger
le droit de penser que quand les gens
ils arrivent au boulot le matin on les
applaudit pas on les maquille pas on
leur donne pas des fringues on leur
donne pas des gauchers de droit de
penser c'est ma pensée j'ai le droit de
penser ça je trouve que là où certains
dans leur camion je trouve que
c'est que c'est pas c'est pas d'hier ça
fait longtemps que j'arrivais sur scène
il a fait des prime sur tf1 ils haïssent
il a acheté une maison pour mieux pour
lui et je vais vous expliquer la
démarche qui me dérange le plus la
démarche qui me dérange le plus c'est
vite fuyons tf1 lui a donné sa chance là
c'est dégueulasse rapidement je vais
dire que ça bah tu vas trouver encore si
les gars s'accrochent pas tu vas trop
longtemps plus des de la
sifa la f1 lui donne sa chance dès
qu'ils voient que le vent il tourne à
bas le kobus j'ai fait mon retour n'a là
elle retrouve à la rue comme de tas de
france a qui sont vraiment à la rue pour
devrait lui qu'est ce qu'il a fait c'est
barrett chez tf1 en disant ces
deux clichés france 2 c'est le pognon
des français qui payent des impôts
il est parti lequel soner il est parti
comme un mercenaire et la sécurité chez
france télévisions m
j'étais contre c'est ce que je crois
c'est d'un énorme contrat est mieux que
tu avais escota c'est ce que pense tu
partiras pas comme un mercenaire pour
pour aller parler ou de remords mais non
puisque moi je dis on est le fait de
dire bonjour j'ai un contrat de
chauffeur livreur chez
riot nolan tout de suite j'ai même
passion c'est que les leçons que j'ai
même pas signer de contrat il n'ya pas
signer le contrat les lyonnais a tout de
suite fait la police brice conca j'ai
signé 0,6 me sortir de là on les connaît
ses
partenaires on peut pas lui reprocher
puisque c'est un père de donner d'autres
jetés orientation à sa carrière il a
quoi ces enfants de la famille parce que
sur tf1 je suis bien placé pour le
savoir avec benjamin et bernard si t'as
pas de contrat d'exclusivité
si tu fais pas d'émission tu n'es pas
payé donc tu n'as rien pas et comme ils
n'avaient pas la scène à côté voilà tout
simplement tu peux pas reprocher aux
gens d'avoir peur de se retrouver lance
jean-françois sajan software maladroit
de dire à calais jusqu'au bout d'une
formation soit maladroite sa formulation
maladroite à greater ya des animateurs
qui ont des gros contrats d'exclus
naples joyeux rien de lui il y en avait
deux encore fois que jean pierre
foucault s'est trouvé un arrangement
avec avec tf1 il est encore sur la
chaîne mais de façon différente oui le
dernier qui reste d'abord je crois que
c'est nikos ouais d'accord mais c'est
quoi nikos et l'animateur qui gagnent le
plus que je fais je vais parce qu'ils
gagnent mais je sais que c'est joli et
la situation est plus étalé sur la
chaîne il avait pris et ça se passe très
bien pour lui il avait dit je pense
qu'il a lui-même euros peut-être défi
dans son contrat qui était pas très bon
je crois au tout début alors allez très
pour moi mes collègues qui défendent
jarryd moi je vous dis il a fait il a
fait ma singer zhari et alors
il va être dans l'émission de la
prochaine saison oui mais si ces
veillées
les gars mais masque singer une
prestation de jury jean dans ma famille
les françaises et les français et
franchement
jamais ça va les rites et coutumes et du
valais le talent est là mais ça ne
croîtra d'exclure mai mais à valérie
c'est un geste que vous disiez faire
j'ai déconnecté charge italie non mais
oui mais laissez moi finir j'essaie de
finir bassin
il a touché il a touché des dizaines de
milliers d'euros pour massing alors la
drôme et ses rires vous pouvez pas vous
plaindre après la descente les plans
finlande et lui se plaint les gens qui
revient dans son club
jean cheveux et je peux très pop mairie
s'est pas avéré que gênant on lui posait
une question et en lui demandant pour
quelles raisons vous êtes parti de tf1
france 2 mais voilà lundi je pars de tf1
prendra parce que j'ai été très gênés
avant ils se sont très bien occupé de
moi mais je me sentais en danger parce
que du jour au lendemain je pouvais ne
plus rien avoir hors france 2 me propose
quelque chose où je pense que je pendant
quelques années en tout cas je suis
assuré le prouvant ainsi la voie à sa va
diriger les panneaux je t'aime beaucoup
valais il est
issu et valérie je t'aime beaucoup vous
voulez dans des métiers de spectacles
vous voulez que ça brille vrai que ça
change je voulais que ça à faire du
silver vous voulez aller faire des
concerts jeux des concerts une passion
mais tu crois que les gens ils n'ont pas
des patients mais tous les matins fois
les bouffer sa passion tu laisse de côté
par ses frères mais non c'est pas démago
si tu as peur de te retrouver sans rien
du jour au lendemain tu vas faire
manutentionnaires
c'est un métier qui brille c'est le
risque regarde y'a des chroniqueurs qui
sont plaints du jour au lendemain c'est
le riz sabri les faits mais je crains
que là c'est le rire mais c'est comme ça
et tu peux pas sortir si maladroit même
consenti civile de dire aux gens j'ai
peur de me retrouver sans rien du jour
au lendemain si tu as peur va chercher
un cd quelque part va chercher un cd ça
fait 28 ans que j'en serais d'accord on
va pas manquer si tu veux venir livrer
tu sera pas sans lendemain et j'aurais
pu mettre connaître encore
cette phrase là tu la sors à chaque
émission et non à cette étude n'est joué
mais c'est quoi le rapport chaque sou
c'est ce que sais tu sais ce qui s'est
passé et avance que tu connaissais vie
ce qui s'est passé encore oui tu
dénonces et qui s'est lancé en car elle
comporte le manque ce mec il s'est passé
en iran au nom de quoi qu'une des noms
s'arrête je dénonce pas jeudi que ses
propos de
donner son avis en train de me parler de
1940 et une phrase on sort une phrase
dans deux semaines ça c'est pas
n'importe quoi c'est juste que vous avez
peur toi la première comptez pas sur la
table pourquoi je suis pas fou
[Applaudissements]
le problème c'est quoi c'est que vous
passez à
jamais le problème de sa le permet de
voir et y est elle est là laissez le
parler vous versez un petit mix esternay
moi je pense pas que c'est par là je
dois je penser que ces éternels et quand
ça s'arrête quand ça s'arrête vous
n'êtes pas content pour toi ça s'arrête
parce que c'est un jeu faut prendre ce
que apprendre faut payer vos maisons
fauves il faut qui fait l'album et b
phone house à berck vraiment bizarre ça
fait dix ans que tu as ppp et je veux
qu'on calcule les dix ans tpp plus ta
carrière sur rtl mais on va trouver
combien
ça fait dire ça fait dix ans qu'elle est
là ce qui pourrait laisser le monde
quand on fait une séquence sur cole
c'est vrai ça pleure après dans les
loges pourquoi vous faites ça pourquoi
vous me faites ça on rigole on est là on
rigole minima ont fait rigoler
et vous vous avez
juste raymond boucher riva travail en
cdi ne sera pas viré c'est peut
comprendre que c'est à 100 à la hâte en
gamme et les suivre et les yeux juste
sellers il souhaite pas que ces maisons
c'est un gentil tu travailles tu
traverses et droite ont travaillé ses
chances d'échapper à laser essayer
d'être digne de la confiance que si et
comment tu serais alors et c'est beau et
c'est pas ça comme définition
merci lisa